it always kind of throws me for a loop
that this movie starts in Chinatown
because that's like the one part of the
film that doesn't look I don't know
christmy the portrayal of Asian-American
relations and Gremlins is actually the
key to understanding the main message of
this film but I'll get into that later
on in the video first I want to
translate these Chinese characters and
see if there's anything interesting
written here for the majority of the
opening there's not but the story that
Mr pelter goes into where he eventually
buys the mwai is called Magic and as he
goes down the stairs the characters
written on the walls mean God and
strange the word magai also means evil
spirit so if you're fluent in Cantonese
you already know that this shop is no
ordinary shop and Billy pelzer's new pet
is no ordinary little creature